bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat ce matin les sénateurs
de la commission d' enquête sur le coût
réel de l'électricité reprennent leurs
travaux ils multiplient depuis février
les auditions ce matin ils entendent
maryse arditi c'est la responsable des
questions énergétiques du réseau france
nature environnement
l'objectif de cette commission denquête
et de comprendre ce qui composent
aujourd'hui réellement le prix de
l'électricité mais aussi de savoir si
l'énergie nucléaire est réellement bon
marché alors tout de suite sans plus
tarder direction la salle clémenceau
poursuivrait cette audition bonne
matinée à tous madame maryse arditi
je vais vous demander de respecter un
petit peu la tradition car devant une
commission d enquête il faut prêter
serment alors je vais vous demander de
lever la main dryden ans est restée
assise de dire de j'avais demandé de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
de lever la main droite et de dire je le
jure levé la main droite et vous dites
je le jure et bien sûr merci pour
avancer tout de suite dans le sujet
notre rapporteur jean desessard vous a
envoyé un questionnaire de manière vous
permettre de préparer il va si ça ne
vous en dérange pas répéter les
questions pour qu'elle soit bien
enregistrer et puis nous allons vous
demander d'y répondre plus nous laisser
un petit déçu d'y répondre en 35 40 mais
une pas plus de manière à nous laisser
aussi un petit temps de des changes de
questions complémentaires si vous le
voulez bien
jean oui merci monsieur le président
madame maryse arditi pilote du réseau
énergie je vous ai adressé quatre
questions
première question quelles actions
convient-il prioritairement de mener
selon vous pour encourager la sobriété
et l'efficacité énergétique que vous
préconisez dans le domaine de
l'électricité
le mécanisme des certificats d'économie
d'énergie vous paraît-il efficace et que
pensez-vous des divers dispositifs
fiscaux éco prêt à taux zéro crédit
d'impôt de vous
quand durable à destination des
particuliers seconde question quelle est
la position de france nature
environnement sur le chauffage
électrique est troisième question pensez
vous que la france devrait soit
prolonger la durée de vie des centrales
existantes soit investir dans le
développement de nouvelle génération de
réacteurs ou envisager une sortie aussi
rapide que possible du nucléaire un tel
choix sur est il compatible avec une
augmentation de la taxe carbone et avec
le développement de nouveaux usages
comme par exemple la voiture d'être et
dernière question selon vous quelle part
de la production électrique française
devrait être assurée par des énergies
renouvelables quelle appréciation portez
vous filière par filière sur les
différents mécanismes de soutien
énergies renouvelables et le caractère
intermittent de la plupart des énergies
renouvelables ne l'est quand elle ne les
comptons tonne-t-elle pas un rôle
d'appoint en matière de production
d'électricité
merci monsieur reporter madame merci à
vous je vais donc essayer de faire un
peu plus bref que ce qui était prévu
dans ma tête
d'abord juste une chose pour dire que
pour france nature environnement s'est
vraiment l'efficacité énergétique et au
delà la réduction des consommations qui
est le coeur de la problématique
énergétique avant la deuxième question
de savoir comment on approvisionne ce
qui est nécessaire
alors c'est difficile en france même
difficile en europe puisque vous savez
que l'europe qui avait au début fait
dans le paquet des trois fois 20 je vous
rappelle que l'efficacité énergétique
n'était qu une ardente obligation mais
n'était pas obligatoire et aujourd'hui
on entend d'essayer de faire une
directive là-dessus justement parce que
ça n'avance nulle part sur l'aspect
électricité le coeur de la problématique
le résidentiel et tertiaire
donc pour aller droit au but et faire
plus bref on a deux mesures extrêmement
importante qui n'existe pas encore à
vous proposer
la première c'est de dire que toute
résidence où tout local tertiaire
qui on va dire une passoire c'est-à-dire
qui lorsqu'on fait un diagnostic se
situe dans lève j'ai h puis enfin etc
devraient pouvoir ne devrait plus
pouvoir être ni loué ni vendu à une date
donnée et pour un niveau de performance
donnée par exemple on dirait à partir de
on ne peut plus venir louer une fois
qu'il est vide et bien sûr ni vendre une
maison ou une résidence qui a un
coefficient de permanence j'ai alors je
dis 2015 faut laisser du temps pourquoi
et puis après on dirait deux ans plus
tard les gens savent qu'on ne pourra
plus louer ou vendre une maison qui
aurait un coefficient de performance
f ceci parce que l'objectif essentiel
est sur l'existant que le grenelle avait
fixé un objectif de -38% sur l'existant
à l'horizon 2020 et qu'on est très très
très très loin de cette courbe et qu'on
n'y arrivera pas s'il n'y a pas des
mesures réellement règlementaires et pas
seulement des mesures où on laisse le
marché libre essayer de remplir de tels
objectifs
mais j'y reviendrai un tout petit peu au
moment des cee
deuxième élément essentiel il faut et là
c'est un élément un peu fondamentale si
on veut aller vers une société de la
sobriété
il faut qu'on arrête de penser que plus
on consomme et moi on vous le vend cher
d'ailleurs voilà si si le premier on
vous le fait un certain prix mais si
vous n'en prenez 3 ou le fait moins cher
il faut qu'on aille en sens inverse
et donc ce que nous demandons d'ailleurs
pour l'eau comme pour l'électricité
comme pour les réseaux c'est une
tarification progressive
c'est dire qu'au contraire les premiers
kilowattheures nécessaires sont à des
prix accessibles à tous mais ensuite les
paliers supplémentaires monte alors il
faut faire très attention étudiante et
d'ail les effets pervers faut pas que
quelqu'un qui ait pas qui est dans une
maison pas soit parce qu'il peut pas
louer autre chose soit
soit fortement impacté donc il ya des
tas de détails techniques et sociaux à
regarder mais si vous voulez c'est deux
éléments absolument essentiel c'est un
il faut une rénovation absolument massif
seule la réglementation y arrivera et 2
il faut changer nos mentalités en disant
plus consommer plus payent et non pas
plus consommer moins je paye
voilà donc ça ces deux éléments clés je
fais exprès un peu court de deux
éléments essentiels qui explique
pourquoi on a tellement de mal sur
l'efficacité énergétique
c'est le moment de la décision et le
choix de la décision et ça va faire le
lien avec les certificats d'économie
d'énergie
le moment de la décision en gros quand
l'énergie coûte pas cher c'est pas la
peine de faire des économies vous vous
dites j'investis temps ça va me
rapporter très peu de choses il faudra
25 ans pour l'amortir c'est pas la peine
je le fais pas et puis quand le prix de
l'électricité à doubler ou tripler ou de
l'énergie en général salih al assad vaut
le coup faut le faire sauf que le le
particulier par exemple où
l'entrepreneur qui doit investir à ce
moment comme le coût de l'électricité ou
de l'énergie les coûte trois fois plus
cher il a plus les moyens de faire donc
il ne fait pas donc voilà on est au
coeur de cette problématique qui est le
problème du moment de la discussion
il faudrait faire les il faut faire les
économies d'énergie elles sont plus
faciles à faire au moment ils
apparaissent plus rentables et dans
notre système économique c'est dur de
faire passer cette idée
ensuite il ya la deuxième idée qui est
le choix de la mesure
et là on exactement sur ce qui s'est
passé dans les certificats d'économie
d'énergie le choix de la mesure
mais puisque c'est ça on va faire les
mesures les plus rentables
alors quand on regarde ce qui s'est
passé je fais la transition vers la
certificats d'économie d'énergie
on voit que plus des deux tiers ça a été
les changements de chaudière dans des
maisons passoire évidemment dans les
maisons qui consommaient beaucoup donc
on change la soutenir pour une claire
plus performantes ça se rentabilise pas
assez vite
sauf que évidemment d'ici cinq ans on va
penser qu'il faut réellement isolé et à
sang la faudra à nouveau changer la
chaudière parce qu'elle sera
surdimensionné donc plus adaptée
donc on a eu un effet pervers qui
consiste à dire je vais aller chercher
le petit truc rentable on a vu que 25% a
consisté à mettre des doubles vitrages
c'est stupide pourquoi parce que pour
les gens un simple vitrage vous savez
enfin bon moi je suis une femme et je
travaillais dans la cuisine ça ruisselle
c'est très désagréable l'ong a nous la
victoire service help you donc voilà
sauf que c'est totalement inintéressant
pour les économies d'énergie par rapport
à la rentabilité c'est absolument nulle
par rapport à l'investissement
donc si vous voulez on a les certificats
d'économie d'énergie
on a obligé les gens à y aller ce qu'on
appelle les obliger à nous on dit bien
ce que ça veut dire
ils y vont le dos au mur et à reculons
faut qu'il trouve des gens qui vont
faire des économies ils cherchent tous
sexes est le moins cher possible à faire
des économies pour arriver à les emmener
pour pas avoir leurs deux centimes de
pénalité et le résultat c'est que
finalement on a eu des résultats qui
sont pas très probant à ce jour je
voudrais dire une deuxième chose qui me
paraît très important que c'est que pour
vous bien sûr qui est des spécialistes
le kilowattheure cumac lui térawatts
heure du mat n'a aucun secret mais quand
on parle du grand public
le souvent le cumac disparaît et donc on
imagine - c'est super quand même là en
quatre ans et demi on a fait six
térawattheures d'économie d'énergie
c'est bien non non on a fait 75 watts
heure pardon économies d'énergie
drôlement bien non on a fait grosso modo
quand vous passez des cuma côté
rabatteurs normaux à la louche vous
diviser par dix quoi donc en fait on a
fait six térawattheures en trois ans bon
voilà à ce rythme là ça va ça fait 0 5%
par an à l'horizon 2050 on n'aura rien
fait quoi donc on doit absolument
changer de braquet et il faut comprendre
il faut faire attention à cet effet
pervers du cul matches je les ai vus sur
des revenus compris des revues de
qualité quoi sur l'énergie qui tout à
coup avait sauté le cul match bon voilà
donc je vous le dis chaque fois qu'on
dit quand vous entendez dire on va faire
en trois ans veut faire 300 carats
ouattara lors tout compris un
combustible énergie machin etc
ouais en fait c'est c30 donc voilà donc
ça fait 10 à la fin la veille par année
donc voilà on est quand même dans des
zones plus que raisonnable trop faible
bon j'ai pas l'étendre puisqu'il faut
aller vite sur les aides fiscales juste
un mot un on a on a des problèmes de
précarité énergétique considérable
considérable c'est pas la peine
d'attendre dans un fauteuil que les gens
viennent vous voir si vous voulez il ya
une expérience intéressante c'est celle
de 1981 82 où il a été créé l' agence
française pour la maîtrise de l'énergie
qui est l'ancêtre de la dden aujourd'hui
on a dit à cette agence on met ce
pactole sur la table de milliards
d'argent de l'état vous avez 18 mois
pour qu'ils lèvent grosso modo cinq fois
le montant de travaux dans toute la
france et puis c'est à vous de le faire
vous allez cherchez vous allez des
marchés vous y allez vous attendez pas
qu'on vienne vous voir dans 18 mois faut
que ce soit pas font tous les travaux
sont engagés pas finie et tous engagés
voilà ça c'est une vraie mais voilà ça
c'est une vraie volonté politique faut
savoir que sur l'efficacité énergétique
contrairement à ce qu'on dit sur plein
de choses ce n'est pas la technique qui
pilote c'est le politique s'il ya une
volonté politique s'avance y en a pas
enfin un dernier mot avant de passer à
la question d'après le livret a ldd
on sait enfin je veux dire comme ça
c'est carrément une arnaque
il s'appelle livret développement
durable il vient de la tradition c'était
un livret codevi vous rappelez donc pour
les pmi pme
normalement chaque année sur cette zone
de livrer là il aurait dû y avoir 9,2
milliards d'euros pas tout à fait rien 9
il ya 2 milliards d'euros prêtés pour
faire des économies d'énergie produit
développement durable en fait on à 2,7
et le reste les banques se les gardent
elles en font ce qu'elles veulent elles
l'auraient dû obligatoirement déposées à
la caisse des dépôts ciel ne prêtait pas
elles l'ont pas fait
donc on si vous voulez pour le pour le
citoyen est là pour le coup que je suis
j'ai un livret développement durable et
il sert pas à ce qui à son nom alors ou
bien on lui change son nom ou bien on en
fait un autre à côté en garde un codevi
ou c'est pas une ancienne version et ont
fait un vrai livret développement
durable
même moins important mais qui ne servent
qu'à ça et qu'on puisse pas détournés
la position de france nature
environnement sur le chauffage
électrique dont je pense que vous la
connaissez
je voudrais quand même cette occasion on
y re 2 3 2 3 mots parce que si on
comprend pas ce qui s'est passé sur le
chauffage électrique on ne comprend pas
comment la france est arrivé à cette
situation
seul dans toute l'europe mon seul au
monde je rappelle quand même que chaque
fois qu'il ya une vague de froid la
moitié de l'appel supplémentaire de
puissance dans l'europe des 27
c'est pas rien dans l'europe des 27
c'est nous à nous tout seul marqué les
autres du coup ils peuvent nous envoyer
là ils sont en voit plein l'allemagne
pendant la crise du foie on parle
beaucoup de l'allemagne là qu'il a sauté
pendant la crise du fln a envoyé de
l'énergie a pas de problème parce que
non ça va faire donc qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé on a eu un programme archi
surdimensionné je suis ici devant une
assemblée parlementaire
je veux dire que ce programme a été
initié et réalisé sans qu'à aucun moment
ni les citoyens ni les parlementaires
n'étaient concernés
on vous a pas demandé ni avoue sénateurs
il ya vos collègues députés
2 si vous avez un avis là dessus on a
engagé la france dans la situation où
elle a aujourd'hui sur le tout nucléaire
sans avoir jamais eu aucun avis la seule
fois où on est venu finalement in fine
et demandé leur avis aux députés aux
sénateurs au regret de vous le dire
c'est le jour où elle a fallu gérer les
déchets nucléaires
là effectivement le gouvernement ne
suffisait plus à lui tout seul face aux
assauts paysans et les forces qui se
levait en vendée il s'est dit me faut
une légitimité de plus en mai chez les
déchets nucléaires ça va être très bien
pour les parlementaires
voilà excusez moi de le dire comme ça
mais quand les gens essayent de
comprendre pourquoi sur le nucléaire
plus difficilement que partout ailleurs
les associations sont réticentes aux
concertations
si à cause de ce péché originel alors ce
qui s'est passé c'est qu'en plus cela
surdimensionnement a été tel que dans
les années 84 85
au lieu de subventionner les économies
d'énergie qui a comme ça avait commencé
en 81 82 83 à partir de 80 cartons
arrêter de subventionner les économies
d'énergie et on a subventionné le
transfert du pétrole à l'électricité
puisque les centrales elles sortaient 6
par an et les gars n'est pas la
consommation en france donc fallait
absolument que
qu'on se met à le consommer et ce
phénomène a été encore aggravée parce
que ne voyant pas comment faire pour
arriver à consommer toute cette
électricité supplémentaire que la france
n'avait jamais eu tant d'électricité ni
autant de besoins
il n'y avait pas de solution il fallait
rentrer sur le marché du chauffage que
tu es le seul marché très important sur
lequel on aurait pu y aller donc on est
rentré à fond sur le marché du chauffage
et des faits a réussi à obtenir à
l'époque une loi absolument incroyable
dix ans on peut faire une maison sans
conduit de fumée
comprenez bien que dans tous les gens
qui font des maisons individuelles là
sur catalogue etc
le conduit de fumée c'est cher si je ne
mets pas de conduits de fumée et carré
place se dit a pas de problème je vais
un petit grille pain dans chaque caisse
parce qu'un radiateur électrique sendai
pain donc je m'inscris pas dans chaque
pièce et ben y'a pas de problème ça
coûte beaucoup beaucoup moins cher
résultat les gens vont de plus
volontiers sa puis font la promotion
regarder s'il est vraiment pas cher et
10 pas aux gens que ça va leur coûter
après très cher à se chauffer donc on a
vu cet effet qui fait qu'on a eu le
droit de faire des maisons sans conduit
de fumée jeu pendant très longtemps mon
cas et une vingtaine d'années comme ça
où il ya plein de maisons compact
conduits de fumée en refermant
aujourd'hui c'est cher et le dernier
point c'est le plus scandaleux je
voulais l'amener en power pack mais je
savais pas qu'on pouvait en ferrain mais
je voulais enverrait si vous me donnez
un mail et vous pourrez le regarder
c'est la publicité ddf en 90 91
publicité qui dit grand quand vous
sortez de chez vous ne coupez pas votre
chauffage électrique alors oui parce
qu'en rentrant vous aurez plus à faire
durant toute une pub autour de ça
absolument fausses comme quoi on peut
faire des pubs food en france semble
arriver à voile à mai donc si vous
voulez elle disait bien mais on sait
plus quoi en faire
les premières exportations d'élèves vers
l'étranger sont partis vers 92
donc là on s'est dit il faut absolument
que j'arrive à trouver d'autres clients
j'y arriverai pas je pourrais pas faire
vous manger toute cette électricité aux
français c'est impossible
donc je trouve des clients à l'étranger
donc voilà comment on est arrivé voilà
comment on en est là donc je voulais
quand même le dire donc vous avez
compris que nous on pense c'est très
simple on pense qu'aucune électricité
qui est une énergie très noble une
énergie qui demande beaucoup de
d'efforts pour l'afer qui demandent du
gaspillage qui n'ont aucune ne doit de
gaspiller en électricité on doit
l'utiliser que pour les romands pardon
excusez moi en chaleur où on utilise
pour
de l'électricité spécifique nous avons
tous besoin d'ordinateur enfin
d'éclairage de choses comme ça on peut
pas faire autrement sans électricité ou
l'utilisent pour des systèmes
industriels très performant ou par
exemple d osmose inverse c'est dix fois
plus économique que si on essayait de
faire la même chose avec la chaleur donc
là oui voilà donc c'est clair il ya un
vrai besoin d'électricité
mais compte tenu de ce qu'on perd pour
la produire il faut là il faut
l'utiliser à bon escient
alors durée de vie sa centrale nouvelle
génération ou en sortir bon je vous
savez que la position de france nature
environnement évidemment d'en sortir si
je puis dire le plus rapidement possible
dans les délais raisonnables qu'il est
possible d'envisager mais je voudrais
quand même dire deux choses d'abord
prolonger les centrales de toute façon
on va aller prolongée des attributs pour
30 ans ça y est fessenheim a déjà trente
trois ans on voit bien que elles vont
être prolongées bon allez on va dire
jusqu'à 40 ans on peut pas faire moins
ondra arrête
réceptionnant le ce qu'on appelle les
inventaires des déchets les comptes
jusqu'à 50 ans et df est en train de
préparer les 60 ans je trouve que c'est
un pari de pascal pari de pascal dieu
existe ou n'existe pas
l'accident il sera la wii sera pas je
vous rappelle que ya quatre grands pays
nucléaire au monde à 50 1 4l états unis
la russie le japon et la france les
trois précédents ont eu leur accident
gravissime
tu as à qui le tour je vous rappelle que
il était prévu en 1973 dans ce qu'on
appelle rapport à ce mini scène à
l'époque qu'il y aurait un accident
nucléaire gravissime fusion de coeur et
sait tous les sens tous les millions
d'années réacteurs nous en sommes à 14
milles arrondissons 15000 année
réacteurs on a eu cinq choeurs gravement
atteints donc on est à plus de 200 fois
la probabilité qui était prévu au départ
je vous rappelle aussi que le nucléaire
bien entendu tout le monde envie
d'entamer n'assure pas ces risques c'est
à dire que à tchernobyl comme à
fukushima est comme ça arriverait si tu
es en france c'est le citoyen et l'état
qui paye et df est assurée pour chaque
accident à hauteur de 91 millions
d'euros
tchernobyl des centaines de milliards
fukushima pour l'instant on avoisine les
100 milliards mais on sait pas combien
ce sera quand on aura fini un nom mais
j'aime quand ça monte au fur et à mesure
c'est une pente ascendante
donc voilà donc on comprend bien qu'on
n'ait pas serait autrement dit et df le
risque qui est pris il est pris par un
exploitant qui lit mais c'est moi qui
prends la décision c'est moi qui l'ait
gdf
alors non je vous rappelle quand même
qu'edf certains exploitants comme tout
le monde et df le pâton ddfc vous savez
peut-être pas mais le patron d'ilfc
l'état donc c'est vous
donc il ya un moment donné le risque
faudra de savoir le bénéfice et df qu'il
enlevait le risque c'est les citoyens
qu'ils payent alors donc je voudrais
alors sur ce un peu donc nous évidemment
pense qu'il faut en sortir assez vite
les quarante ans on peut pas faire moins
mais à mon avis
outre 40 et 45 ans il faut faut les
arrêter quoi four parce que après après
c'est pas possible
alors mais ça veut dire c'est sa boucle
avec le premier point sur les économies
d'énergie bien sûr
alors nouvelle génération eh ben on est
on est un vrai carrefour là en gros là
parce qu'on fera jamais les 2 1 la
france c'est pas la peine il sait pas
faire les deux où on repart vers du
nucléaire quatrième génération on y va
70 là on fait à peu près autant que ce
qu'on ait cetera pour 60 ans - où on
part vers les renouvelables le qui ont
parfaitement les capacités de produire
largement autant surtout dans le temps
on y reviendra donc où on part vers les
renouvelables mais on fera pas les deux
en france ont fait pas les deux ont
d'ailleurs la preuve c'est parce qu'on a
beaucoup de nucléaire qu'on n'a pas fait
de renouvelables voilà quand les autres
démarré à fond non on n'en a pas fait
passer les gens vous disent mais
pourquoi on en ferait nous on a on a
déjà pléthore de nucléaire
en électricité aux autres c'est pas la
peine d'en faire donc effectivement on
ne fera pas les deux donc on est un vrai
carrefour alors sur ce carrefour moi je
voudrais tout de même dire quelque chose
sur les coûts même si voilà sur les
coûts moi quand j'ai lu alors j'avais lu
à l'époque en état il rapport de la cour
des comptes de 2005 sur démantèlement et
déchets et j'ai relu en survolant cette
fois ci le rapport de la cour des
comptes de cette fois ci il ya une chose
qui m'a fait sursauter
c'est le coût du démantèlement
le coût du démantèlement ils étaient
évalués grosso modo à que je me trompe
pas sur les chiffres 300 euros du kilo
watt
c'est la commission paix ont revu
réactualisé remis enfin je pense que
dans d'autres gens ont dû vous vous
l'expliqué en détail c'est voilà ça date
de l'époque on disait après 15 % de ce
qu'on a investi pour le démantèlement
puis on a réactualisé
bon ce mandat on est à 60 euros 300
euros 300 euros le kilowatt heure ce qui
nous emmène donc ça on fait le calcul
pour brennilis brennilis est presque pas
encore finie développe et met presse
maintenant on en a déjà fait plus de la
moitié donc on sait à combien ça va nous
amener
grosso modo ça va nous amener à eux 500
ha ben ouais ça ça évalué selon la
commission paix ont ça devait faire 20
millions d'euros et nous allons en est
on en est à 492 millions d'euros à la
louche 500 donc on a un exemple où on
dit ça va faire 20 fois ce qui était
prévu et la commission qui vient de se
terminer
je vous je vous lis le paragraphe un peu
surprenant parmi ces coulées vertes
dépenses de démantèlement c'est à dire
les dépenses de démolition des centrales
sont estimées aujourd'hui à 18,4
millions d'euros 2010 en charge brute
pour le démantèlement des 58 parc du
réacteur donc on est sur les 300 en
question à des broutilles
la commission considère que les méthodes
utilisées par edf pour le calcul sont
pertinentes mais ne peut invalider les
paramètres techniques en l'absence des
buts approfondie par deux experts au
moins je pense qu'elles ne sont pas
pertinentes
je voudrais vous dire trois choses la
première c'est que à la demande de
france nature environnement et plus
spécialement à la mienne
on a demandé une journée de formation
pour les associations sur le
démantèlement
parce qu'ensemble c'est un pro 1 quelque
chose qui émerge comme problèmes
réellement de manière forte
pas encore pour les 58 réacteurs actuels
mais pour ceux qui sont déjà arrêtées et
la filière française depuis les ul gégé
est là qui sont arrêtés vannes ont un
peu en à retirer le combustible et puis
on on tourne autour on sait pas quoi en
faire
donc celle là on avait envie de savoir
où on en était donc on a eu une journée
qui a été fait par l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire ou et des f1
areva le ceva sont venus nous ont dit il
en était ce qu'ils ont fait c'est moi
j'ai posé une quête à un moment donné et
df nous donne un tableau où elle dit
pour chacune des ong nous dit là on a
fait 15% la 18% la 22 % auquel nous dit
où elle en est un jeu qui va très bien
donc je lève la main je dis juste une
question ça ça va être plus facile parce
que les dépenses futures
c'est toujours aléatoire mais les
dépenses passées celles là normalement
on les connaît qui est ce que vous
pourriez de mettre en face de chacune de
ces centrales combien vous avez dépensé
à ce jour donc moi même qui tête c'était
6 et 15 % s'il nous donne le chiffre je
pourrais multiplier par six et la
réponse a été annoncé à ses secrets
c'est de l'argent dépensé finit bien et
je ne comprends pas a dit messi c'est
une opération commerciale vous comprenez
nous ont fait un appel d'offres
l'appel d'offres c'est top secret c'est
commercial donc on dit pas combien ça va
coûter ensuite celui qui emmène l'appel
d'offres mais ils dépensent ce qui veut
le moins possible c'est son problème
pourvu de non contrôle qu'il a fait
comme il fallait
mais nous on n'a pas à voilà résultat
d'aujourd'hui on a un tableau où on sait
pour chacune des six centres des
descentes à l'ulg g 7 août entre 10 et
20% à peu près 1 le tableau qu'on nous
avait donné mais moi je ne peux pas les
deux chiffres a compté pourtant ça nous
aurait permis d'avoir une idée de chaque
côté de ce tableau ça leur a permis de
nous avoir une idée
les autres peut-être que brennilis est
un cas particulier qui fait 20 fois
peut-être que les autres ne feront que
10 fois
peut-être qu'elles font que cinq fois
enfin j'aimerais avoir un chiffre voilà
et je pense que le moi je quand j'ai lu
le machin c'est le point le plus faible
de tout dossier alors sur ce
démantèlement un dernier point pour nous
c'est vraiment le point faible le
conseil supérieur de prévention des
risques technologiques qui s'occupe
normalement qui regardaient jusqu'à
présent fin jusqu'à décent
dernier il ne regardait que ce qu'on
appelle les risques industriels
chimiques la pétrochimie etc
les installations classées pour la
protection de l'environnement depuis sa
nouvelle version est depuis janvier
il s'intéresse aussi au nucléaire donc
les arrêtés du nucléaire sont vus dans
cette commission
donc on a eu deux premiers gros
s'arrêter nucléaire celui qui va
légiférer à partir de maintenant les
nouvelles jmb ou par exemple flamanville
et penne ici à nice est hélas il ya
écrit il devrait y avoir un plan de
démantèlement mis dans le temps là deux
mondes du permis de construire
d'exploitation dire qu'on sache comment
on finira alors on a levé la main on a
dit bon on est très contents que pour
les prochaines six années prochaines on
face à ce qu on pourrait écrire que pour
celles qui existent là les 58 qui son
fonctionnement et qui n'ont pas de nom
de démantèlement donc comment voulez
vous qu'on évalue combien ça coûte
puisqu'il ya plan de démantèlement
forcément eh ben eh bien on n'a pas
réussi à le faire mettre dans l'arrêté
donc il ya 58 réacteurs qui n'ont pas de
plan de démantèlement comment vous
l'évaluez combien ça va coûter
voilà donc jeu j'arrête là dessus juste
un dernier mot quand même sur les coûts
le le nucléaire c'est une courbe de
désapprentissage message suspense que
j'ai pas la première avoue l'avoir dit
normalement au fur et à mesure qu'une
technique se développent les coûts
baissent voilà les coûts baissent et
bien le nucléaire vous pouvez regarder
depuis les premiers jusqu'à aujourd'hui
les coûts l'écoutent d'un je parle
d'investissement est à dire le coût de
la préparation de l'arrêt du réacteur
nucléaire n'ont fait qu'augmenter et
vous pouvez regarder aujourd'hui si vos
savoirs entre ça et les énergies
renouvelables
les coûts des énergies renouvelables
vous le savez sont en baisse donc c'est
non pas très très longtemps que les
cobras on se croisait meilleur sur sur
l'augmentation des coûts je vous
rappelle que quand il a déposé
quant à edf a déposé le dossier
flamanville elle a écrit dans le dossier
flamands disent ça fra 42 euros le
mégawattheure si de nouvelles c'est un
peu plus cher entre les autres par 42
quand elle a déposé flamanville pardon
qu'on allait déposer penny seulement
cinq ans plus tard et c'était le
deuxième
donc le premier avait dû rodez c'était
le deuxième on était passé à 55 à 60
et naturellement on sait aujourd'hui
qu'on sera plutôt à 70,80 parce que ça
c'était avant l'augmentation des coûts
de l'investissement est à dire avant le
dérapage complet du coup qui a quand
même doublé mais on est passé de 3
milliards à 6 milliards
pas sûr qu'on arrive au bout et pour six
milliards sais pas si vous avez un jour
eu le canard enchaîné vous avez vu le
béton qu'on nous fait avec des trous
j'en voudrais pas pour ma maison quoi
donc voilà alors j'ai un coffret deux
compères quatrième temps j'ai bien
accéléré alors je préfère me laisser un
peu de temps alors quatrième question
sur les énergies renouvelables
alors combien les énergies renouvelables
pour être assuré de la partie résiduelle
de nos besoins
ça dépend de l'horizon temporel en 2050
je pense 80% en 2100 la totalité ce
qu'il faut garder en tête que les nerfs
le flux solaire et ses dérivés le vent
l'hydraulique etc
tahir tout sauf la géothermie ça
représente chaque année comme énergie
arrivant sur terre cinq mille fois la
consommation de toute l'espèce humaine
sur terre
si on arrivait un jour à dire qu'on
prend un pour me valorise un pour mille
pour nous vous pourrez ouvrir grand les
portes de la pléthore énergétique à
l'ensemble de la planète sans que ça
impacte rien donc c'est un horizon
temporel et c'est un horizon temporel si
on veut y aller
voilà donc alors est-ce que comment ça
se passe aujourd'hui le soutien aux
filières alors le soutien aux filières
puisque j'ai gagné un petit peu de temps
je joue je vous dis quand même deux mots
de l'année qui a été pour moi l'année
noire et pour 20 stature environnement
l'année noire
ces 2010 je rappelle quatre décisions
mars 2010 lancement de des autorisations
d'exploration des gaz de schiste avril à
juillet 2010
débat public sur le second au pm juil
2010 les éoliennes entre dans les
installations classées pour la
protection de l'environnement
autorisation stats hier parmi les
cinquante mille usines les plus
dangereuses de france et décembre
moratoire sur le photovoltaïque
quatre mesures une pour soutenir les
fossiles une pour soutenir le nucléaire
une pour plomber l'éolien une pour
plomber le photovoltaïque
vous analysez ça comme vous voulez mais
voilà la lfc cas des faits alors comment
on raisonne par filière alors pour
soutenir la filière seul fonctionne
réellement
le tarif de rachat garanti
les appels d'offres pour fonctionner
jeudi peuvent
je pense qu'ils peuvent fonctionner pour
des très gros projet on va dire comme
l'éolien en mer par exemple d'accord
mais je vous rappelle quand même si par
hasard vous l'aviez oublié qu'en 2004 il
ya déjà eu un appel pour l'éolien en mer
le concours a été réussi il ya eu une
personne qui a été retenu un exploitant
qui a été retenu
et ça ne s'est jamais construit et quand
le gouvernement a donné là les gagnants
des quatre concours il a dû bien entendu
vous avez maintenant à faire toute la
procédure administrative qui font
jusqu'au bout et il n'est pas dit que
vous irez au bout
l'intérêt de l'appel d'offres c'est que
sa garantie qu'on n'en fera pas plus que
ce qu'on a voulu mais on pourra en faire
beaucoup moins voire pas du tout
l'éolien a démarré en 95 avec un
objectif de 50 mégawatts par an jusqu'en
quand on est arrivé en 2001 c'est à dire
six ans après on avait fait 60 mégawatts
alors que sa femme mégawatts en effet 60
mégawatts on a compris qu'on ne fera
jamais voilà donc l'appel d'offres c'est
en gros un objectif surtout pas en faire
trop donc effectivement il ya un pas on
est on est effectivement opposé ça
marche pas alors les points clés sur la
filière éolienne alors affiliés à voir
yens sony filière
sur réglementé j'aurais pas le temps de
vous détailler mais c'est
invraisemblable on n'a jamais vu dans
aucun pays au monde pour une filière qui
est quand même pas si dangereuse que ça
une réglementation aussi invraisemblable
mais aussi c'est vraiment hallucinant
non on en a rajouté la loi grenelle ii
on a rajouté avec plein de bonnes alors
avec plein de bonnes intentions va faire
des schémas régionaux éoliens
résultat les services de l'état on y va
en attendant afin que les schémas soit
fait pour commencer à les instruire les
dossiers et puis on a mis les icpe en
icpe n'est ce pas on a pas qu on n'a pas
osé les mettons seveso classés mais elle
s'était presque quoi on se demande où
sont n'avons cherché je vous rappelle
que le rapport de ton nom m'échappe de
deux kits du gars qui a fait le truc sur
les députés du touquet absolument très
fondamentalement anti éoliens dont le
nom est en train de m'échapper il avait
dit oui icpe c'est pas très bien voilà
le mari de madame la ministre des armées
ouais si on ne s'était pas lui le
rapporteur
oui mais enfin je rappelle quand même
qu'ils étaient 2 qui en inquiète parti
avant la fin cali je m'en vais je ne
peux pas tout
je ne peux pas acté ce qui a là dedans
le résultat se prépare t il disait lui
même il disait lui même les icpe sait
pas très bien pour les éoliennes ça
marche pas mais on va quand même le
faire et puis enfin les choses en plus
parce que comme ça marche passait mais
voilà c'était vraiment l'idée comment
est ce que je peux en rajoute et voilà
bon alors résultat quand même
après tout après tous ces efforts le
résultat est enfin là en 2011 nous avons
installé 30% des aliens de moins qu'en
2010 je pense que c'était l'objectif
recherché si ce n'était pas l'objectif
renchérissent d'un hommage mais 30% de
moins pour la première fois depuis que
la vie revienne ont démarré 30 % de
chute
alors alors qu'il faut quand même savoir
deux choses premièrement c'est que
l'éolien terrestre est à la marge de la
rentabilité là pendant la crise du froid
la période de froid la hanche en février
ont un acheteur rte est d'être acheté le
coup le water éolien moins cher que ce
qui rachetait à tous les pays étrangers
pour approvisionner notre notre pointe
d'électricité en france on en était à
117 ont racheté
l'éolien là à 82,84 donc il ya eu déjà
d'il ya déjà des périodes de forme lui
demander à tous les spécialistes de ça
il ya déjà plusieurs périodes par
paquets où on a racheté il ya moins cher
c'était le cas en 2008 tous avec ans
quand tout d'un coup les combustibles se
sont envolés on a acheter moins cher bon
mais je voudrais parce que il se trouve
que j'ai aussi une autre casquette à
forte allure environnement où je
m'occupe des risques industriels et moi
je voudrais vous dire que le fait on est
en ce moment si vous voulez on a un
nombre de gens limités pour surveiller
les cinq cent mille installations
industrielles en france dont 50 milles
qui sont les plus dangereuses qui son
autorisation
on a 12 100 inspecteurs wave ou fait le
poids à quoi donc
résultat on est on est en manque
résultat il y a des lois qui sont passés
juste au même moment pour dire faut
absolument aller j'ai ça donc on va les
regarder dans toutes ses installations
qui existent lesquels on pourrait sortir
de l'autorisation en quoi pour pour
gagner du temps d'inspecteurs pour les
concentrer sur les trucs les plus
dangereux on l'aimé à autorisation à l'
enregistrement sa truc intermédiaire
auquel et nous nous sommes violemment
opposés parce qu'il s'agit d'aller
chercher des des choses déjà vraiment
très polluantes ou très dangereuse et de
la m comme ça en avec très peu de
contrôles et au même moment on va dire à
ses inspecteurs vous allez nous
contrôler des dossiers entiers de
d'études de danger sur les éoliennes
enfin ça c'est de l'incohérence totale
c'est s'ils voulaient c'est vraiment on
n'a pas de temps à perdre d'inspecteurs
de l'installation classée on en a passé
aujourd'hui sur des risques vraiment
sérieux au moment où on essaye de mettre
en place la loi bachelot et les plans de
prévisions les plans de protection des
risques technologiques etc
on n'a pas les moyens de gaspiller comme
ça du temps inspecteurs donc moi je vous
le dis là vous êtes une représentation
nationale
on est un peu de cohérence
alors les photovoltaïques non sur le
photovoltaïque
aubin pas de problème le moratoire a
probablement atteint là aussi une partie
ses objectifs
on évalue un peu grossièrement on a du
mal parce que c'est par petits paquets
par paquet de 2 5 10 personnes à chaque
fois
grosso modo on évacue on évalue la perte
d'emplois sur l'année 2011 dans le
photovoltaïque aux alentours de
plusieurs milliers d'emplois
certains lisent autour de 7000 7000
emplois dans le silence le plus total
vous avez entendu personne en cause et
ça gêne pas on aura à peut-être qu'un
endroit 300 personnes mais au sommet sur
le nucléaire ça fait des scandales là
dans le silence le plus total
on a tué une filière et des millions
émergents un problème ce ne sera qu'une
personne juste un mot quand même qui
pourrait être un mot très important
d'améliorations qui est je pense une
erreur en france on a exigé ce qu'on
appelle pour le particulier kilomètres
de photovoltech sur son toit on à exiger
l'intégration au bâti
alors ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
quelqu'un qui a une maison depuis 20 ans
avec une toiture en excellente état
il voudrait mettre du photovoltaïque il
faut vous casser votre toiture qui est
étanche qui est parfait en de l'état et
iron man ou la remplacer par un truc qui
évidemment a toujours un risque
d'étanchéité sur une filière émergente
où les problèmes de bacs de raccordement
et ses courses des problèmes
évidemment ça coûte trois fois plus cher
puisque j'ai couple casser la bon mais
en allemagne il est sûr impose ça coûte
infiniment moins cher
du coup on n'a pas besoin de
subventionner autant parce que c'est
beaucoup beaucoup moins cher on a aucun
risque d'une étanchéité
donc du coup les gens ils ont plus
volontiers enfin voilà donc il ya
quelques erreurs là qu'il faut peut-être
arrivé à rectifier bon juste deux mots
justes pour dire stop stop aux
agrocarburants vraiment là on est sur
une filière absolument impossible stop
aux agrocarburants et dernier mot sur
l'intermittence
alors l'intermittence 1
y'a pas de problème aujourd'hui en
france avec ce qu'on fait comme
pourcentage non deux comme il y en a
d'autres qui sont bien plus avancés que
nous ils vont avoir réglé le problème
avant nous on va voir ce qui se passe au
danemark qui fait déjà plus de 20%
d'électricité éolienne on va aller voir
ce qui se fait aux au portugal qui
décolle à toute vitesse on va le voir ce
qui se fait ailleurs et ils auront
trouvé les solutions avant nous et pour
nous et troisième chose il ya un élément
quand même qui est très important c'est
que il faut du stockage il faut de la
recherche sur le stockage d'électricité
par seulement sur les batteries sur les
volants d'inertie sur les
transformations sur plein de choses
j'ai cru entendre un jour que notre ceo
a était devenu le commissariat aux
énergies à l'énergie atomique et aux
énergies alternatives on espère qu'on
n'a gardé qu'un seul césar on espère
qu'à promouvoir qui a le premier regard
desquels deuxième bafoue lui demander de
se mettre aussi fait les énergies
alternatives de se mettre à la recherche
sur le stockage de l'énergie d'ailleurs
je crois qu'il l'a déjà entendu parce
qu'ils avaient vu des lignes qui
commencent à apparaître
voilà et dernier dernier point
personnellement mais ça c'est vraiment
une opinion personnelle je pense qu'à
l'horizon 2050
l'hydrogène aura trouvé sa place bien
écouter merci beaucoup pour la passion
que vous avez amené dans vos
explications qui sont très précises et
que nous connaissions un petit peu déjà
je voudrais simplement je vais donner
parle à mes collègues vous demandez une
première chose mais pas d'y répondre
maintenant j'aimerais beaucoup puisque
vous avez travaillé dessus tout le
premier volet de votre intervention
c'était sur l'efficacité énergétique
vous avez déjà travaillé sur la
directive où on sort un petit peu du
sujet et ça m'intéresserait beaucoup que
vous nous envoyez à récrire après à côté
votre position sur l'avancement de la
directive parce que directive européenne
elle évolue elle change
on a commencé à travailler ici au sénat
d'ailleurs plus pure plus en amont de
l'assemblée nationale sur la première
version de cette directive de cet avant
projet de directive ça a changé et je
serai très intéressé d'avoir la position
de 2
votre position de super donc là je vous
pose pas de questions sur une des
questions de notre rapporteur qui est un
point sur lequel j'aimerais bien que
vous donniez plus de précisions c'est le
laquelle la question sur la taxe carbone
il est évident que quitter plus ou moins
rapidement le nucléaire pour rentrer
dans le renouvelable ou dans une période
intermédiaire faire appel à d'autres
énergies de substitution
si on en sent trop vite ça aura un lien
direct avec la taxe carbone et
j'aimerais bien avoir votre position là
dessus et dernier chose mais ce n'est
pas une question c'est une précision que
je voudrais vous donnez nous les
parlementaires et sénateurs nous sommes
nous aussi inquiété sur le coup le coût
de la le coût de la sa du solaire non
non pas du tout du démantèlement nous
avons posé les mêmes questions que vous
avec beaucoup avec beaucoup d'insistance
nous a commencé à avoir des débuts de
réponse ça ne sera pas confidentiel ce
sera dans le rapport du rapporteur et je
crois que nous rendrons publics les
chiffres que nous avons alors uniquement
c'est pas pour les meufs mais pour les
sept centrales de la toute première
génération celle des déesses puisqu'on
aura on n'a pas les chiffes du d'areva
mais on aura les chiffres de sept des
neuf centrales et le rapporteur les
virages certainement dans son rapport
sur ce qui a déjà été dépensée ce que
vous dit tout à l'heure
depuis depuis 2002 2000 à aujourd'hui
donc là c'est pour vous pour vous
rassurer nous comment semer mais nous
aussi nous avons eu du mal je voulais
vous dire sur la taxe carbone s'il vous
plaît pendant que si ma la taxe carbone
elle est une évidence mais je l'avais
moins mis en avant parce qu'elle est
plus une évidence sur le climat que sur
l'énergie elle même alors pour nous
c'est pas une taxe carbone c'est une
contribution climat énergie c'est très
important
pourquoi c'est pas une taxe carbone
c'est une contribution climat énergie
c'est à dire que pour nous on doit taxer
les deux éléments 1
il ya une taxe en fonction de l'énergie
elle-même d'oeil à une taxe en fonction
du contenu en carbone
justement pour parce que notre objectif
c'est effectivement d'aller vers une
société où on ne gaspille pas l'énergie
quelles qu'elles soient alors je pense
qu'il faut regarder quand même qu'il ya
déjà des pays qui l'ont fait la suède a
une taxe qui est aujourd'hui
alors ceci plus je crois qu'on n'est
plus loin de son taureau quelque chose
comme ça alors je sous toute réserve
en fait c'est devenu très élevé parce
qu'elle a commencé il ya longtemps et
elle augmente progressivement
donc effectivement il sera plus facile
de la faire sur l'europe que de la faire
sur la france seule mais je pense que si
déjà la france avait une position
offensive
ce serait déjà bien je vous rappelle que
sur la la directive européenne la france
a une position en retrait comme tous les
autres comme tous les autres pays c'est
à dire que le le passage de la
proposition excusez-moi justin de la
proposition de la commission à la
commission du conseil des ministres a
réduit drastiquement toutes les
ambitions
voilà donc alors je pense que ce qu'il
faut faire attention à cette taxe est un
la justice 2 l'aspect social et 3 et on
ne peut plus la faire comme on le
pensait la faire de manière brutale
parce que nous arrivons
on va arriver en janvier 2013 dans très
peu de temps et je vous rappelle que la
le ce qui avait bloqué sur cette taxe et
qu'on avait exonéré les entreprises et
aux hervé n'exonérant ouais mais elles
vont piller en 2013 les quotas donc
c'est normal et c'est d'abord on sait
aujourd'hui qu'il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui paieront par les
quotas qui vont être exonérés donc
faudra voir qu'est ce qui reste
donc il y avait une étude complète ça
nous paraît indispensable on va dire
dans la mandature qui vient faut que la
contribution climat énergie a été mis en
place mais je pense qu'elle redemande
cette fois ci compte tenu de nouveaux
éléments compte tenu de tout ce qui
bouge de partout
compte tenu quand même des dead tard
éléments qu'on bouger dans tous les sens
des uns et des autres ça demande une
étude approfondie cette fois ci voilà
mais je crois que voilà ton il faut pas
la faire dans l'est dans les six mois
parce que les trucs qui sont faites trop
précipitée sont pas bons pas
suffisamment calais et je pense que ça
paraît indispensable
merci bien cherche
merci madame pour votre exposé les
énergies renouvelables vous l'avez
souligné ont des problèmes
d'intermittence nous avons à faire des
recherches beaucoup plus prégnante sur
le stockage de l'énergie
la filière photovoltaïque a été
complètement déstructuré et il ya eu de
la casse au niveau même de l'emploi vous
l'avez souligné
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il faudrait ouvrir
un débat sur la maîtrise publique du
secteur de l'énergie pour réorienter les
dépenses et pour qu à coût constant
comme on le fait aujourd'hui on puisse
faire réellement face aux défis qui sont
devant nous dont l'on est ce qu'il est
d'actualité d'ouvrir ce débat pour une
maîtrise publique et ce qu'on doit aller
vers ça compte tenu de d'une
diversification des allées des avancées
des reculs et d'une complexité de
l'ensemble
alors j'aurais envie de dire
oui à condition que la maîtrise publique
ne soit pas seulement une maîtrise est à
tiques
mais une maîtrise citoyenne regardant si
vous allez voir dans des par exemple je
prends un exemple au danemark
vous ne pouvez pas faire un champ éolien
s'il n'ya pas 20% d'argent citoyens en
france regardez la complexité et la
difficulté qu'ont à le faire on est en
train d'essayer de faire émerger les
choses mais c'est extrêmement difficile
nous notre idée il faut faire très
attention c'est que quand on parle
maîtrise publique
on a tendance nous en france à penser et
des f&a dire à penser centralisée et sur
les énergies renouvelables
il faut penser décentralisée public mais
décentralisée public citoyen mais
décentralisée d'ailleurs aujourd'hui et
ça ça veut dire j'en dis un mot
là-dessus il faudrait pouvoir demander
données justin à côté mais donner des
pouvoirs législatifs ou des pouvoirs
réglementaires un certain nombre de
choses dans des communes où dans des
grandes intercommunalités
je rappelle que barcelone par exemple a
pu et genève aussi prendre la décision
de dire il n'y aura pas un immeuble
nouveau s'il ya pas un chauffe eau
solaire d'un chauffe-eau papa papa photo
vlp pas thermique un thermique classique
aucune aucune collectivité en france n'a
le droit de dire ça donc voilà donc
l'idée c'est parce que quand on
réfléchit si vous voulez énergies
renouvelables il ya vraiment deux
chemins et je vous remercie d'avoir un
beau buzz et de cette question est
vraiment de chemin il ya vraiment un
chemin on nationalise tous et nous ont
dit si on amène à ce que j'ai l'air si
on a été obligé je dirais presque de
sortir du domaine public et ddf pour
arriver à faire un peu d'énergie
renouvelable en france il ya quand même
des dommages à dire mais voilà c'est la
situation qui est comme ça donc on a si
vous voulez en face de nous deux grands
chemins
si je caricature des énergies
décentralisées citoyenne public comme
vous voulez mais ont majoritairement
mais décentralisée ou desertec
si je caricature c'est une desertec sais
je rêvais des milliers de mètres carrés
dans le désert et puis j'en vois une
grande ligne et puis ça provient de
toute l'europe
on a évidemment radicalement opposées à
cette deuxième version est
s'il ya des moyens pour faciliter la
prise en main par les citoyens qui
veulent investir qui veulent y en a qui
disent ils mais moi c'est bien moi je
fais un petit peu de sous plutôt que de
les mettre dans n'importe quelle action
ski pin moi je veux bien les mettre dans
dans un champ d'éoliennes
ça me paraît un élément essentiel mais
voilà mais sous cet angle heures
décentralisée et citoyens monsieur le
rapporteur est ce que vous avez à peu
près réponses à toutes vos questions ou
est ce qu est l une route qui lequel
vous souhaitez y avoir un complément
alors monsieur il n'y a pas de question
je ne vais poser une sur le certificat
d'économie d'énergie cd re on a eu des
des propositions diverses lors des
différentes auditions
certains disent que si le fait qu' on
devrait davantage
il devrait y aura une répartition
différente propriétaires locataires
enfin bon il y avait toute une
réorganisation donc est ce que vous
pouvez être un peu plus précise sur le
bilan de des certificats d'économie
d'énergie et les incitations ben ça
tombe bien parce qu'il est la première
réunion à la suite de la table ronde sur
l'efficacité énergétique capa est sorti
énormément de choses dans cinq a dit
qu'il fallait commencer à préparer la
troisième le troisième temps 2 à partir
de 2014 jusqu'à 2017
et donc voilà ça fait un an et demi pour
préparer on a eu un peu le bilan
alors on voit un que les certificats
d'économie d'énergie
finalement sont relativement pas si
présent que ça dans la rénovation
grosso modo le marché de la rénovation
couvre 11 % il ya 2 % qui correspondent
à des certificats d'économie d'énergie
alors il ya le vrai problème du
certificat d'économie d'énergie c'est
qu'on passe par des obligés c'est-à-dire
par des gens qu'on pas très envie d'en
faire je sais pas si vous voulez puisque
finalement ils sont obligés mais ils
n'ont pas très envie d'en faire donc je
ne sais pas c'est un outil qu'il faut
garder sa note il faut garder
mais je trouve que c'est un outil qui
essaient de kiki qu'il faut absolument
arriver à régler une partie de ses
effets pervers tiers cas par exemple on
ne peut plus il faut alors le plan le
plan bâtiment de pelletier les a soulevé
ses effets pervers les effets pervers
c'est par exemple de faire que qu'un
petit truc
donc il faudrait qu'il y ait par exemple
qu'on ne puisse avoir un certificat
d'économie d'énergie que sur des projets
globaux un peu important que soient pas
des ou au moins de deux trois trucs soit
pas que des petits morceaux
voilà ce que je disais tout à l'heure
25% des sortir d'économie d'énergie sur
des doubles vitrages
on est complètement à côté de nos pompes
voilà donc s'ils voulaient c'est un
petit 1 1 peut enfin moi je
en plus je vais vous dire tout de suite
les réticences pour la troisième
cette commission il y avait tout le
monde puisque c'était pour lancer le
projet etc
les réticences sont déjà absolument la
légende et buste en sport 10 mais on
fera pas la moitié de ce que vous avez
et puis on n'en fera pas les autres
disent non mais vous faut pas en faire
plus on peut pas enfin bon donc je et
c'est pour ça que je pense que la seule
vraie mesure
alors après on peut discuter qui paye
comment on paye commencent à se
répartissaient de dire on ne vend plus
on ne rejoue plus à partir d'un certain
niveau de 2 de dégradation et de
passoire jean-jacques dans ce jeu je
vous signale quand même que dans la
directive européenne sur lequel il
travaille à bruxelles
on s'inspire notamment des certificats
d'économie d'énergie français et anglais
pour tenter de l'étendre à l'ensemble
des européens
donc oui ça peut perfectionner mais
c'est pas ce nom c'est un peu ça marche
pas si mal que ça et c'est ça va dans la
bonne direction tout les cas josiane
aussi un outil amplifier la constructi
vous avez évoqué mme lam tout à l'heure
le concept de citoyenneté à ce qui
concerne le passage jamais tant
l'administration de tout ce qui concerne
l'éventualité des énergies renouvelables
je note au passage du reste que si on
rentre en configuration tel que vous
l'avez évoqué d'une forme de
décentralisation ainsi concerne tout ce
qui est un commentaire région par région
et j'ai peur qu'à terme si on écarte une
institution quelle qu'elle soit l'état
par exemple de ses capacités régaliennes
ça se fera sur des critères qui seront
vraisemblement des critères économiques
ou des critères fiscaux --dont deux fait
tu auras des régions des départements
qui seront laissés pour compte
mais ma question est pas exactement
celle là j'aimerais savoir quel est
votre point de vue par rapport au fait
que actuellement face à ce problème là
on a affaire à des disparités qui sont
évidentes
quand je dis ça je pense singulièrement
à des gens qui pour des raisons
sociologiques et économiques passent
complètement à côté cette dispositif et
cette mutation que vous avez plaideuse
nous devons mieux que nous appelons
aussi de nouveau à mon sens
préférentiellement c'est une évidence
serait réservé à ceux qui dans
l'ancienne utilisation des énergies au
sein de larges ont tout vu et tout connu
et mois l'inquiétude qui est la mienne
c'est de me demander comment est ce à
rejoindre l'ue reste un peu ce qui a été
évoqué par macway comment on peut
arriver à faire en sorte que l'ensemble
des consommateurs
jose padilha des citoyens consommateurs
de ce pays soient concernés de produits
faute de quoi l'assistera une logique
qui consisterait à dire aux uns encore
et toujours le high tech et puis aux
autres qui ne sont même pas au début du
commencement de de pouvoir envisager ne
serait ce que des économies d'énergie
parce que tout simplement sur le plan
économique il ne nomme pas les moyens
voila j'aimerais voir mais d'une manière
générale comment vous pouvez arriver si
vous voulez afficher ce concept mais en
faisant en sorte qu'ils concernent le
plus grand nombre même s'il est
souhaitable et paris alors je pense que
las alors j'ai dit deux choses quand je
pense que j'ai été vite là dessus j'ai
dit deux choses comme et j'ai dit il ya
le problème de la précarité énergétique
qu'un souci numéro un si vous avez
regardé sur le site de france nature
environnement on a mis l'aspect
précarité énergétique en avant un
sélectif mans là il s'agit même pas de
dire aux gens ils vont économiser de
l'énergie oui dans certains cas il
s'agit de leur faire économiser
d'énergie mais enfin au moins déjà
qu'ils accèdent au confort c'est à dire
que ils consomment la moitié de ce
qu'ils devraient consommer et hisse au
gel ils ont des moisissures et les
gamins ils sont malades
enfin et c'est donc si vous voulez nous
on a un vrai souci là dessus c'est à
dire que il est hors de question mais on
pense que une tarification progressive
et je l'aï dit tout à l'heure en faisant
attention aux effets pervers
karine tarifs une tarification
progressive elle a pour objectif quand
même de dire tous ceux qui vraiment
gaspille allègrement bas qui gaspillent
en payant cher c'est à dire qu'ils ont
les moyens s'ils ne le font pas donc
voilà donc ça c'est une première chose
la deuxième chose c'est la précarité
énergétique sur sa compagne dire que moi
j'ai entendu philippe pelletier dire on
n'a pas réussi à réduire parce que le
grand emprunt nous a mis un paquet sur
la table mais on nous a dit attention
ont dépensé même 3% pour faire de
l'accompagnement pour aller aider les
gens à prendre conscience de ce qu'il
pourrait faire et donc du coup il dit on
n'a même pas pu tout dépensé sur
certains points donc on a ici un vrai
problème les gens qui sont en situation
de précarité
il faut aller les accompagner mais faut
pas croire certains même enfin moi je
fais des conférences sur la précarité
énergétique ont expliqué aux gens même
s'ils n'avaient aucun moyen
comment vous voyez un tout petit peu
améliorer votre confort en consomme ap
pas plus parce que vous regardez votre
maison on sait comment on peut faire
évident mois il ya des choses qu'on peut
faire vous pas rentrer dans le détail
mais j'ai fait de la formation sur la
thermique du bâtiment donc voilà on vit
une vie antérieure
et donc si vous voulez il ya déjà au
moins des choses qu'on peut expliquer
aux gens est absolument indispensable
parce que effectivement pour le coup
nous quand on quand on a un discours on
a un discours qu'on veut porter par
l'ensemble des citoyens on est bon quand
on additionne tous nos membres les uns
après les autres ça nous fait huit cent
mille personnes mais pour nous c'est la
majorité des citoyens qui compte c'est
pareil
y en a qui y voilà donc si vous voulez
on a un vrai souci là qui consiste à
dire mais faut pas croire on a dans des
milieux ruraux en particulier des gens
en situation difficile mais qui savent
malgré tout faire des économies n'est
guère eu besoin de pas grand chose pour
pouvoir le faire bien donc voilà donc ce
discours c'est un discours qu'il faut
effectivement mais je suis d'accord
absolument accompagner mais la
tarification progressive est un peu un
signal alors quelqu'un m'a dit c'est pas
un signe à ses au moins un signal
écologique qui n'a aucun impact négatif
socialement moi je dis il peut même
avoir un impact positif mais enfin voilà
on a au moins déjà ce discours là ça
nous paraît important
même dame a dit si je remercie beaucoup
je suis d'accord avec vous la précarité
énergétique est un vrai problème pas
facile à traiter ça concerne beaucoup
plus que les 800 mille foyers qui ont
droit à cette aide publique 1 ça
concerne probablement 4a à 6 millions de
foyers des gens qui n'ont pas les moyens
de faire des travaux nécessaires qui les
aiderait pourtant à payer leurs factures
c'est un vrai un vrai gros problème de
tout cas merci beaucoup merci pour la
manière passionnée donc vous vous êtes
exprimés ça ne nous a pas surpris
voilà pour cette audition merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi si vous souhaitez
revoir les travaux de la commission d'
enquête sur le coût réel de
l'électricité
notre site internet publicsenat.fr très
belle journée à tous